Let's look at the solution to our
2-way set-associative cache quiz.
As before, the answer to this
type of question requires us to
figure out which bits in the address
determine what in the cache.
So the address will be broken
into offset, in this case 5 bits,
index, in this case, two bits to tell
us which set we have, and a tack,
seven bits are used by the index,
and the offset, with means,
that the index will be determined by
the least significant two digits.
So we can figure out
that 0003 is like this.
Five bits are the off set,
the next two bits are the index.
So this maps to set zero,
and we will put F303 there.
Next one is F503.
It maps to the same set but
this set now has two places,
so we can actually put F503 in
the other line in that set.
Next, we have F563.
6, 3 is like this.
This maps to set number 3,
and finally EF63,
is going to map to the same set,
and we'll put it here.
So as you can see, with the 2-way set
associative cache, we can put more than
one block that maps to the same place
in the cache and not have conflicts.
This is why we want to
have a 2-way cache or
more because it reduces
the number of conflicts.
However, it complicates the tagged
checks because now when
we're looking for something we
have two places to search before
we're sure whether it's there or not.